ahora que el frío se instala de nuevo en
españa 10 municipios de la comunidad de
madrid incluida esta ciudad tendrán que
imponer medidas restrictivas a la
movilidad de sus residentes una nueva
acción coordinada en salud pública con
medidas muy importantes en este momento
de la pandemia en relación a unos
determinados territorios de nuestro país
que cumplen unos criterios
y a las medidas asociadas a estos
territorios este este acuerdo ha sido
aprobada con una amplia mayoría 13 votos
a favor una abstención y 5 votos
negativos 13 votos afores y un 70% de
los miembros del consejo le han dado
apoyo y por tanto constituye una
decisión colegiada del sistema nacional
de salud de las nuevas medidas que serán
publicadas en forma de decreto en los
próximos días afectarán a todos los
municipios españoles que presenten más
de 500 casos de coronavirus por cada
100.000 habitantes y una ocupación de
las unidades de cuidados intensivos que
supere el 35 por ciento madrid es una de
las ciudades que tendrá que aplicar las
nuevas restricciones anunciadas pero el
gobierno regional se ha opuesto y
aseguró que es una decisión sin validez
jurídica e intervención en su autonomía
madrid- actualmente es la comunidad
autónoma que está peor y es verdad que
hay que tomar medidas para que esto no
empeore y nos lleve a un segundo
confinamiento
y es y aquí estoy tomando medidas pero
no obstante pienso que el segundo
confinamiento no esté efectivo porque
económicamente españa no se lo puede
permitir porque ya sólo vale ver con los
datos del pip y todo esto que va a bajar
pues que no es viable los habitantes de
los 10 municipios donde aplicara la
medida tendrán prohibido los viajes por
placer y las fronteras de cada ciudad
estarán cerradas a los visitantes
extranjeros